EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
IMPEACHED, THAT'S THE WORD WE
HAVE HEARD FROM THE HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI WHO
EFFECTIVELY CONFIRMED IT DURING
A SHORT DRESS THIS MORNING.
ON THE ONE HAND, THE NEWS IS NO
SURPRISE AT ALL, APPROXIMATELY
100% OF MSNBC VIEWERS HAVE BEEN
DEMANDING IMPEACHMENT SINCE WELL
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THEY WOULD BE BAFFLED AND
ENRAGED OF DEMOCRATS PULLED THAT
NOW.
THESE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE TRUMP
NOT ONLY WORKS DIRECTLY FOR ARCH
VILLAIN VLADIMIR PUTIN BUT ALSO
ONCE HAD AN EXTRAMARITAL AFFAIR,
SOMETHING THAT PARTY OF
POLYAMORY CLAIMS TO OPPOSE.
FROM STAGING AND OPEN REBELLION,
SHE HAS NO CHOICE BUT TO
CONTINUE WITH IMPEACHMENT.
AND YET, THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
AS MUCH AS JEFF ZUCKER SUPPORTS
IMPEACHMENT, NORMAL PEOPLE FIND
THE WHOLE THING BIZARRE.
EVEN VOTERS WHO DON'T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP AND DIDN'T VOTE FOR
HIM LAST TIME DON'T THINK HE
OUGHT TO BE REMOVED BY CONGRESS.
FOR STARTERS, THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE CRIME IS,
SOMETHING ABOUT UKRAINE AND
HUNTER BIDEN.
SOUNDS KIND OF SHADY BUT IS IT
WORSE THAN THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC?
MORE PRESSING THAT HEALTH CARE
COSTS WHICH ARE RISING FASTER
THAN WAGES?
FILL IN THE BLANKS FOR THE
ISSUES THAT CONGRESS COULD BE
HANDLING IF IT WEREN'T FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
NOW IMPEACHMENT DOESN'T REALLY
RIGHT ON THAT LIST.
ISN'T THAT ELECTION 11 MONTHS
AWAY?
WHY CAN'T WE WAIT UNTIL THEN TO
SWITCH PRESIDENT IS, ISN'T THAT
HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS?
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT PELOSI AND HER PARTY WILL
HAVE TO ANSWER AT SOME POINT,
PROBABLY NOT TOO FAR FROM NOW.
IMPEACHMENT WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY TURN OUT TO BE A
POLITICAL DISASTER FOR THEM.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BENEFIT.
PELOSI SEEMS TO KNOW THIS.
SHE DIDN'T GET TO BE SPEAKER
BECAUSE SHE IS BAD POLITICS BUT
BUT YOU CAN'T ACKNOWLEDGE IT OUT
LOUD, SO LIKE THE BRITISH ARMY
DURING THEIR RETREAT, SHE PUTS A
BRAVE FACE ON A DOOMED MISSION
AND FIGHTS ON.
HE WAS HER EXPLANATION THIS
MORNING.
>> WE BEGIN WHERE OUR FOUNDERS
BEGAN WERE IN THE COURSE OF
EVENTS, IT BECOMES NECESSARY FOR
PEOPLE TO DISSOLVE THE POLITICAL
BONDS WHICH HAVE CONNECTED THEM
WITH ANOTHER.
WITH THOSE WORDS, OUR FOUNDERS
COURAGEOUSLY BEGAN OUR
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE FROM
AN OPPRESSIVE MONARCH FOR AMONG
OTHER GRIEVANCES REFUSAL TO
FOLLOW RIGHTFULLY PASSED LAWS.
IN THE COURSE OF TODAY'S EVENTS,
IT BECOMES NECESSARY FOR US TO
ADDRESS AMONG OTHER GRIEVANCES
THE PRESIDENT'S FAILURE TO
FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE LAW.
>> Tucker: IT IS JUST
MESMERIZING ON MANY LEVELS.
WHAT DID IT MEAN, EXACTLY?
IT WAS A METAPHOR.
TRUMP IS A SLIGHTLY MORE ORANGE
VERSION OF KING GEORGE THE
THIRD.
DEMOCRATS OF THE PATRIOTS
PLOTTING TO OVERTHROW HIM WITH
VIOLENCE.
THAT STRIKES YOU AS ALARMING,
PELOSI HAS A FEW WORDS OF
COMFORT.
A GROUP OF 18TH CENTURY
SLAVEHOLDERS SHE ASSURES US
WOULD HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY IN
FAVOR OF WHAT SHE'S DOING.
>> JAMES MADISON, THE ARCHITECT
OF THE CONSTITUTION WARNED THAT
A PRESIDENT MIGHT BETRAY HIS
TRUST TO FOREIGN POWERS WHICH
MIGHT PROVE FATAL TO THE
REPUBLIC.
ANOTHER FOUNDER FEAR THAT A
PRESIDENT MAY BE BRIBED BY A
GREATER INTEREST TO BETRAY HIS
TRUST.
HE EMPHASIZED THAT THIS
MAGISTRATE IS NOT THE KING.
THE PEOPLE ARE THE KING.
>> Tucker: SO JAMES MADISON
HAS GIVEN NANCY PELOSI'S
PERSONAL SEAL OF APPROVAL.
REMEMBER THAT THE NEXT TIME
PELOSI'S ACOLYTES TRIED TO PULL
ADDISON STATUE OFF HIS PEDESTAL
FOR CRIMES AGAINST PROGRESSIVE
ORTHODOXY.
THEY ARE BEING PRESENTED AS
HEROES.
ENJOY IT WHILE IT LASTS.
THE FRAMERS WERE READ THAT
CORRUPT AMERICANS MIGHT TAKE
MONEY FROM FOREIGN POWERS TO DO
THEIR BIDDING AND THAT IS WHY WE
NEED TO BE IMPEACHED
DONALD TRUMP, GET IT?
WAIT A SECOND, TRUMP DIDN'T TAKE
MONEY FROM UKRAINE.
HUNTER BIDEN DATA.
TRUMP JUST POINTED THAT OUT.
HE WAS ON JAMES MADISON'S SIDE,
VIGILANTLY POLICING BRIBERY BY
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER AND FOR
THAT HE MUST BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
POSITION AND IF YOU ARE NOT SOLD
YET, IF YOU SENSE THERE MIGHT BE
A FEW LINKS MISSING FROM THAT
LOGIC CHAIN, NANCY PELOSI HAS AN
ANSWER FOR YOU, NOT SO MUCH AN
ARGUMENT AS IT IS A CLICHE BOMB.
DESIGNED TO CONVEY THE
IMPRESSION THAT IMPORTANT FACTS
ARE BEING DELIVERED AND PROFOUND
THINKING IS TAKING PLACE.
IS LIKE THAT OLD DON McLEAN
SONG.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY MEAN
ANYTHING BUT IT MOVES YOU
ANYWAY.
LESS IN THE NANCY PELOSI'S
RENDITION OF IT.
>> THE REPUBLIC, IF WE COULD
KEEP IT, SAID BENJAMIN FRANKLIN,
OUR DEMOCRACY IS WHAT IS AT
STAKE.
THE PRESIDENT LEAVES US NO
CHOICE BUT TO ACT BECAUSE HE IS
TRYING TO CORRUPT ONCE AGAIN THE
ELECTION FOR HIS OWN BENEFIT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ENGAGED IN
ABUSE OF POWER UNDERMINING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND
JEOPARDIZING THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS.
>> Tucker: MAYBE WE ARE BEING
TOO LITERAL HERE, BUT WHAT IS
SHE TELLING US?
PELOSI IS TELLING US THAT IN
ORDER TO HONOR THE SPIRIT OF
BENJAMIN FRANKLIN, WE MUST
SUSPEND OUR DEMOCRACY IN ORDER
TO PRESERVE IT.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN AMERICA,
THE LEFT WAS SHARP AND CLEAR
RIGHT ENOUGH TO SEE THE IRONY IN
A LINE LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE TO TORCH THE VILLAGE TO
SAVE IT, SURE WE DO, MAKE SENSE.
LIBERALS IN 1975 WOULD'VE
LAUGHED PELOSI OFF THE STAGE.
DEMOCRACY MEANS DECIDING THINGS
IN ELECTIONS IT WAS OBVIOUS THEN
BUT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE,
THE LEFT LOST INTEREST IN
DEMOCRACY AND GAVE UP ON IT
COMPLETELY.
BY THE TIME OBAMA ARRIVED, THEY
WERE BRAGGING ABOUT HOW THEY
GRADUATED BEYOND WINNING OVER
VOTERS WITH CONVENTIONAL
ARGUMENTS AND PROMISES.
GOING FORWARD, SHIFTING
DEMOGRAPHICS WAS GOING TO WIN
ELECTIONS FOR THEM NOW AND
FOREVER.
THEY GLOATED ABOUT THAT IN
PUBLIC, WROTE TRIUMPHANT BOOKS
ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP PROVE THEM WRONG,
LEAPT OFF THE FRONT PAGE AND
BEAT THEM IN A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
THE SHOCK WAS SO PROFOUND THAT
HE NEVER RECOVERED.
THE LEFT TURNED AGAINST THE
COUNTRY THAT DISAPPOINTED THEM
IN THE SYSTEM THAT MADE IT
POSSIBLE, OPEN THE BORDER, THERE
WERE OFF THE RESTRAINTS, AND
ERASE THE PAST, WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO REGAIN POWER, WE ARE
FOR.
THAT CAN NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN, IT
WAS TOO PAINFUL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY RESOLVED.
LIKE A REFORM TO DRUM, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY GOT RELIGION.
NANCY PELOSI STARTED TALKING A
LOT ABOUT PRAYER.
>> TODAY, I AM ASKING OUR
CHAIRMAN TO RECEIVE THE ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT.
I COMMEND OUR COMMITTEE CHAIRS
WITH HER SOMBER APPROACH FOR
WHICH THE PRESIDENT HAD NOT MADE
NECESSARY.
IN SIGNING THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE, OUR FOUNDERS
INVOKED A FIRM RELIANCE ON
DIVINE PROVIDENCE.
DEMOCRATS TOO ARE PRAYERFUL.
>> Tucker: IS ANYONE ELSE
ENJOYING THIS?
ADAM SCHIFF'S SOMBER REPROACH?
THAT'S WHAT NANCY PELOSI WOULD
LIKE YOU TO RECALL FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND APPRECIATE
THE DIGNITY THAT BUG EYED
LUNATIC FROM BURBANK BROUGHT TO
THIS PROCESS.
YOU WATCH THE PROCEEDINGS, IT
WAS LIKE BEING IN THE ROOM AS
ALEXANDER HAMILTON COMPOSE
"THE FEDERALIST" PAPERS, A
TRIBUTE GOVERNMENT.
>> I WOULD JUST SAY TO PEOPLE
WATCHING HERE AT HOME AND AROUND
THE WORLD AND THE WORDS OF MY
GREAT COLLEAGUE, WE ARE BETTER
THAN THAT.
ADJOURNED.
>> Tucker: A TSUNAMI OF